hey guys this is andrew for
suresensors.com so i've been working as
a professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong and right now guys
i'm doing youtube videos
because i want to pass the knowledge i
want to show you guys what kind of tools
and techniques pro traders are actually
using
and how to use them so if you want to
know about all the stuff and
basically how to make money on the
markets you are in the right place
so today i want to make an update on amc
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so let's have a look at
the charts so as you can see i have a
lot of different
trend lines so i'm going to explain to
you guys what
trendlines they are and how to use them
so
uh let's start with the lowest one so
basically i check the trend all right so
the trend
is bearish definitely and you have here
a bearish trend and here even even more
bearish trend
so you make for each trend that you can
identify a trend line by connecting the
two recent highs
or more if you have so here i have this
one and this one
and this was giving me here guys and i
was doing videos on this
you know in the past uh month and i was
telling you guys
buy it by bite five is a very nice level
because it was
the re-test of the breakout we had here
so this is the first breakout then we
re-test
and we are going higher so now does the
next resistance uh which just became
support guys
is the one that is given me by the next
trend line that is here guys once again
if you want to do it yourself
don't forget to be on the log scale
otherwise uh you're gonna have something
that is not working your levels are
gonna be wrong so careful
log scale uh if for those kind of very
volatile
stocks so here then uh i drew the
strength line and once again you can see
here that we had the breakout but it
didn't hold so that's why
it's good to trade with the stop loss i
know you guys don't like it but
this is how pro traders actually working
you uh buy
so here for example you can buy it here
at 10 11
even whatever everything that is above
10 is good to buy
if it opens below guys don't buy it so
it's not always
buy low and sell high sometimes it's buy
high and sell higher
right here if i see an open at uh 9
i won't be a buyer but i'm pretty
convinced because i think that
everything is just going higher
that we're going to have a nice open
level or above this trendline which is
going to be
not the confirmation yet this is not
confirmed yes this breakout is
happening but didn't happen yet we need
to have two consecutive
candles above this level so i'm not sure
when i'm gonna publish this video guys
but i'm doing it on
march 10 um and on march 10 guys the
breakout has not happened
yet so whatever if this breakout
confirms you can buy it here guys
and then try to go to the next
resistance level
what else can we say here so let's
quickly have a look at the targets so to
find my targets guys
uh once i have you know a second wave
that is starting so this is a first wave
all right
this is the second wave and this is the
third wave so sorry third wave second
wave is actually corrective
one two three so the third wave is
happening so the question
is where are we heading what is a good
level to sell
i know you guys don't like to sell i
know you like to hold because you like
the stock
but trust me that if you want to make
money you can sell and buy again
later so i'm here to tell you how i
would trade this
so you measured the first wave easy and
you apply the move
up to the bottom of the uh second or
third wave
the same bottom two three all right so
here and
then you uh go from one fib extension
ratio to the next one so 1.618 is the
golden number
it's uh actually a level that we very
often see
playing like acting as support or
resistance so in a case of a move up
it's going to act as resistance here
so the 1.618 35 is a very nice level
guys the next one would be 54. so let's
see what happens here
but you can try to play something like
this
here i think you know 20 is us also a
resistance level
so you can see that it was it's funny
guys to see that you know this
20 and 35 actually the levels that i had
here
20 here is the maximum that we had here
and that was the max that we that we had
here and 25 is just dual time high
so it's funny guys to see that by using
the measuring this wave and applying it
here
the ratios of fibs are giving me those
levels that were printed
a long time ago you know think about it
think about it guys
this is technical analysis and this is
something i see all the time guys this
kind of
coincidence you know feel it like think
the way you want
why this is happening i don't know but i
know this is happening
it's a fact and i just use it so then i
expect something like this maybe here a
bit of resistance but guys let's be
honest this one is not going to be
strong all right the 60
78.6 is not strong at all so it's not
gonna last
we're gonna destroy it if we if we broke
10 on the upside we're going to destroy
the 20 level trust me and the short
interest i'm going to come back to this
very soon is high
so short squeeze might happen and then
we can have something like this
and then bam and then this one is strong
all right this one
is probably going to give us give us
some correction and then
maybe something like this so what i'm
saying is that
taking profits as 20 is
to me not very ballsy it's not stupid
you should buy a 10 you said at 20 you
make 100
but it's not very [ __ ] and this is
not what i would do you know
you need to push your winners to make
money this is how we actually do
we push our winners so here i won't take
profits too early i would take profits
at 35
and then i would reload around maybe i
don't know then i'm going to check on
the shorter time frame what is happening
but i'm going to reload lower very
quickly let's check the short interest
so once again guys for those who are
watching my video i always say the same
thing but
for the new ones it's interesting to
know that i go on market watch and
market bit
and that i cross check this data with
bloomberg because i'm professional and i
have access to bloomberg
15 of short interest here updated on
26th of february
and on market watch market bit amc
if i see the same value i know it's
correct i mean most likely
amc short interest once again guys for
those who think that this
data is intentionally wrong that's not
true 22
all right so we have here a slightly a
small difference
but it's not substantial the short
interest is around 20
so it's less than the other stocks that
i did as well
skt rkt you know they have 35 40
of short interest so amc is not that
shorted because hedge funds are probably
scared
so i don't think we're gonna have crazy
moves up
i mean it can be crazy but it's not
gonna be like one or two days but it can
be
uh full months of uh plus five you know
something like this
uh but i think it's gonna be natural
buyers that are gonna buy this
but it doesn't change my conclusion that
i'm very bullish on this
uh but i expect to see what is happening
around the 10
level before being more confident in
this uh
coming rally so guys that's it for me i
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did please don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys